if we don't want to set the world on
fire then why are we so obsessed with
depicting the end of it from the public
service videos of the 1950s the
irradiated wastelands of the Fallout
franchise the threats of nuclear warfare
looms large over our pop culture but
while nuclear weapons are often the
centerpiece of a lot of the movies and
games we experience they remain in
reality a devastating and immoral force
of destruction so that begs the question
why have we adopted the terrifying
backdrop of nuclear annihilation as a
common setting for our escapism
[Music]
the answer to that question starts in
the real world ashes of destruction
thankfully nuclear weapons have only
ever been used twice in actual war time
the first being little boy the uranium
bomb dropped on Hiroshima on the 6th of
August in 1945 with the second attack
taking place just a few days later when
the plutonium bomb fat man was used on
the city of Nagasaki the destruction was
catastrophic over 200,000 people were
estimated to have died in the attacks
and the cities were left in absolute
ruins covered in layers of lethal
radiation the two bombings brought about
the devastating end to the Second World
War as the Cold War heated up in the
years following World War two the
superpowers of the world raced to build
their atomic stockpiles to the point
that any conflict would involve mutually
assured destruction landed it during
these years of tension between the East
and West the site sound and the threat
of nuclear weapons became unfortunate
part of everyday life from the swathes
of posters propaganda and pamphlets
nuclear bombs became part of modern
society ever-present in what people read
and watched nuclear preparedness films
was shown again and again in the 1950s
from the public service announcement
animations depicts in content families
living in shelters today parodied by
that of four lads vault-tec PSAs to the
likes of the classic 1951 educational
film duck and cover how to survive a
nuclear attack
now tell me right out loud what do you
suppose to do when you see the flash
if only we could all be as prepared as
birth the turtle
while much of the media focused around
nuclear weapons was full of doom and
gloom reminding people about the threat
of annihilation there were those that
found a curiosity sparked by the green
glow of nuclear weaponry these were the
nuclear optimists that either saw the
good of what a nuclear power could do or
just simply had a morbid curiosity about
the potential for big booms and
large-scale destruction bit grim if you
ask me but each to their own
many believes that harnessing nuclear
power would bring about the next
industrial age for the world beyond the
potential for supplying energy amidst
those eager to adopt the atom there was
a general feeling that nuclear power
would make every walk of life better
that it would preserve food power cars
be used for medicine make seawater
drinkable or even irrigate the deserts
the exposure to the threat of a nuclear
attack and the paranoia that surrounded
it may be the seeds of our morbid
obsession with becoming nuclear tourists
at the heart of it was Las Vegas which
during the 1950's earned the nickname
the atomic city due to its proximity to
the Nevada Test Site the city has always
been famous for its lights but between
the 50s and 60s nuclear tourism was
advertised as a way to see a light much
brighter than anything you'd expect to
see on the strip the first weapon test
held the Nevada sight was in 1951 and in
true Las Vegas fashion the Chamber of
Commerce was quick to capitalize in the
spectacle it printed up calendars
advertising destination times locations
that would give you the best views of
the blasts and casinos would offer views
of testing sites as part of Dorne bombed
parties that would finish with the
atomic boom of a test in the early hours
of the morning all while patrons would
be served atomic cocktails by women in
mushroom cloud dresses one gambling
magnate and casino owner even stated
that the best thing to happen to Vegas
was the atomic bomb despite the fear
underlying the conversation on nuclear
weapons discussions around nuclear fire
and annihilation quickly became part of
everyday life within the mainstream and
as such it wouldn't be long until our
nuclear fascination was used as a
springboard for bigger and wilder
fictional stories movies on the subject
of nuclear weapons started appearing in
the early 1950s only a few short years
after the events the end of the Second
World War
1951 saw the release of
which shows five survivors of a nuclear
apocalypse and the iconic Godzilla
arriving just three years later with
director Shira Honda leveraging post-war
Japan's anxieties about nuclear
Armageddon to create a towering
radioactive lizard to deliver a
commentary about the subject from iconic
films like The Terminator franchise Mad
Max and wargames to comic books like
Judge Dredd and manga like Akira as well
as video games such as Missile Command
the original fallout titles an even call
of duty modern warfare 2 nuclear subject
matter has become ingrained in our
entertainment culture all of these
properties are wildly different in terms
of genre and tone but they all share the
common thread of nuclear weapons either
as a setting it's inspiration a plot
point or a gameplay device that gives
players some control over pushing that
big red button in video games perhaps
one of the most iconic uses of nuclear
weapons came in the 80s during the
Golden Age of the arcade and Atari
challenged players to protect unnamed
cities in Missile Command by
intercepting warheads with their own
missiles to prevent cities from turning
into rubble and ruins of course the
inevitability of mutually assured
destruction meant eventually the game
delivered more payload than your
defenses could withstand
from here on out just like in the movies
a site of a nuclear weapon in
entertainment was not an uncommon one
they would become a mainstay in video
games many titles in the 80s would use
the Cold War as their nuclear backdrop
allowing players to influence the
tensions between countries in 1985 s
balance of power defend American shores
from Soviet missiles in 1984 s raid over
Moscow or wage atomic war against
satirical facsimile z' of real world
leaders like Ronnie Reagan and PM
snatcher watching as they grimace at the
world burns around them in 1989 s
nuclear war with the end of the Cold War
in 1991 the games that followed would
often take a different spin on the
nuclear phenomenon as strategy titles
developed it was easier to put the power
in the players hands strategy titles
such as the original civilization
Starcraft and command & Conquer Red
Alert had nuclear weapons as part of
their endgame strategy while the 90s
also developed the post nuclear backdrop
for games and titles like Mad Max
beneath a steel sky and of course the
star of the Fallout franchise the 2000s
however featured some of the most iconic
nukes in the history of games you can't
bring this subject up without mentioning
the nuke at the heart of Fallout 3's
Megaton or the shock and awe nuclear
detonation in call of duty modern
warfare I really
then there are those games that take
place in a post-nuclear setting where
the player exists in a world ravaged by
nuclear warfare and must survive titles
like the Fallout games the Metro series
or Far Cry New Dawn then games like
Battlefield 3 modern warfare Metal Gear
used the looming threat of nukes as a
plot device and then there are some
games that take a more fantastical
approach with nuclear weapons delving
into alternate timelines and what-if
scenarios like that of the modern
Wolfenstein series where BJ blaskowitz
wakes up in a world where the Nazis
developed the atom bomb first Oh many
games put the responsibility in the
players hands allowing them to use a
nuclear weapon as an all-powerful strike
in strategy games like civilization or
command & Conquer or offering one up as
a reward for a kill streak in modern
warfare in fallout 3 and a for entire
quest lines could culminate in a
difficult decision of whether to drop a
nuke or not facing such sobering power
into the hands of the player creates an
interesting dynamic many games are about
empowering the player but that power
comes with serious implications about
how these weapons work in the real world
there's always been a morbid fascination
with the apocalypse within our media and
especially in our games personally I see
it as a sort of bleak playground a
chance to see what a world that we will
hopefully never have to live through
might look like but it often feels like
there's still a moral pull when being
tempted to push that big red button even
in a virtual sense why is it that I have
no worries about going into Megaton and
killing the whole town just so I can
have Lucas Sims hat
who are you just kidding about disarming
that thing but when going down the bad
karma route of detonating the bomb at
the heart of the small wasteland town
I'm so much more hesitant is it that
ingrained old-school propaganda a media
keeping us grounded when the subject of
nukes arise that we've been brought up
seeing the devastation that is possible
we've seen the fear-mongering news
reports and most of us have lived
through some form of nuclear tension
while it's fun to blow stuff up in our
games maybe the site of a mushroom cloud
feels a little too real for many of us
who just want to hit that pixelated
button
with nukes being such a terrifying
phenomenon and so impactful on our way
of life pop culture has an important
role to play in how they're handled in
our interactive media with the events of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki
it's not surprising that the Japanese
version of fallout had major changes to
the power of the atom quest and while
I'm sure you recognize the site of
Megaton blowing up by the players hands
as you watch from tenpony tower in the
Japanese release detonating the nuclear
weapon that resides in the middle of
Megaton was not an option instead you
could only disarm the bomb in a similar
vein one of the most iconic weapons in
fallout is The Fatman mini nuke launcher
the fat man's namesake was actually the
bomb that was dropped on Nagasaki and as
searched the weapon holds the unique
moniker of the Nuka launcher in the
Japanese translation now there are many
fans of the Fallout franchise in Japan
and indeed much of Japanese fiction uses
nuclear weapons and a nuclear aftermath
as their setting but with that being
said some aspects such as allowing
players to the utilized nuclear weapons
against civilian populations and NPCs
are understandably altered
so why then in a real world where
international tensions always seem to be
a certain Heights and superpowers across
the globe is still holding on dearly to
their weapons of mass destruction do we
choose the end of days as a source of
escapism in our games and movies there's
a certain psychology that makes some
people attracted to fear to the
unfamiliar and to struggles sure it's a
diluted version but experiencing our
world it's very worst and in the
hospitable is much like playing a
survival horror game many pursue the
attraction of the unknown and unexplored
or that which provides a window into the
darker side of life we can see from the
monetization of the nuclear phenomenon
both in the rooftop parties of old Vegas
as well as on the early silver screen
that it didn't take long for fear to
develop into intrigue and despite how
dark the core of this intrigue may be
its bled into every form of our
entertainment over the slow decades of
its half-life
either way the Atomic Age has had an
undeniable influence in our pop culture
while the nuclear backdrop may be a
common sight in some of my favorite
franchises the Fallout series being
chief among them I think we'd all rather
look at a mushroom cloud through our TV
screens rather than our living room
windows after all we don't want to set
the world on fire this I'm afraid to say
was the final episode of season 1 of
loadout if you'd like a season 2 then
you need to make your thoughts known in
the comments section down below feel
free to leave your suggestions on
possible future episodes but I'd like to
thank each and every one of you whose
checks out the episodes and stuck by the
series if you've missed the episodes
then well this is the perfect time to
double back and watch them now